watch yourself much or something  [Music]  hey man it's about the car for us bud  stop  stop stop  stop  it's about the car for us  stop both you stop  stop all the car for man all right  no guns on you nothing like that man  all right sit back for him bud we'll  explain what's going on here in a minute  okay step out of the car step out of the  car  okay you don't have a gun or anything on  you right man  all right step away from the car  step away from the car  step away stop  stop  stay there  49 central  stay there  we got him and the zero  stay over there for me step over there  put him up against the front of the car  you freaking stupid  huh you freaking idiot  away from the car  hey  put him in a car  uh can you get him randomly call just  talk to him real quick  brother 49 central if you copy a serial  number on a firearm